but i was born in a Austrian city that
was one of the heaviest bumped during
the Second World War and my first
memories of course I faceted that has
been burned down that there was
basically know how standing and but at
the same time there was a magnificent
surrounding of lakes and mountains and
my burden since I was able to walk took
me out to the mountains and to his two
and a half years I was planning on a
pair of ski and since then I have not
stopped skiing and I have not stopped
climbing mountains so it was somehow
this contrast between a broken-down city
and and the day at the perfect nature
which which somehow formed certainly
part of my character no doubt about it
the other thing was that it was a time
where nothing could be worse only things
only thing could be better and therefore
there was an embedded optimism in the
people in general everybody was
optimistic everybody was thinking that
tomorrow will be better than it is today
and I think that's another part that has
certainly formed my character that I'm
very very optimistic about things in
life and that I always look forward to
see how you can find solution to
problems
well the beginning was very ugly stik if
you want I mean I was just coming back
from the first Austrian hindu kush
expedition where we tried to climb this
high mountains in Alpine style which was
at that time quite revolutionary and
coming back I had to confront reality
that I needed to work and that I had to
make my own living and on the other hand
I really wanted to continue to be able
to climb mountains and I knew that Latin
America would be one place where I could
combine both things so I presented
myself to quite many multinational
companies and I always said these are
any possibility to go to Latin America
one day and until I came to this ice
cream and frozen food company which was
called windows Europa as I said I didn't
know it belonged to nesslun it happened
that I also spoke Swedish it was Findus
was a Swedish company and the before
Maya was answered positively in the
sense that it was head luck we engage
you of Austria but if you really do very
very well there might be a possibility
for you somewhere in Latin America and
that's about why I started business land
that's how it all came about
well I i started to mention that in the
60s of course 68 you know very well what
the public opinion was and that from a
political issue it was the area of
socialism it was the area of
anti-capitalism it was the area of
against multinational companies which
then led to policymaking that said that
the future would be joint ventures for
example I mean in many parts of the
world you were not allowed to have one
hundred percent for an own company if
you wanted to be in the photo you wanted
to be in the retail sector and things
like this so state intervention was
extremely important import subsidy
import substitution was very important
so if you wanted to sell something you
had to produce locally you were not
supposed to import the usage of local
raw materials and so on and so on so it
was a very heavily I would say state
intervened Society of that time well
like in most of those things there is
change and in Latin America without any
doubt the biggest change factor was p
noche who really introduced back
introduced a more open society a free
economy and with this fantastic success
economic success of his regime many many
other Latin American countries followed
afterwards opened up the markets free
the economy and suddenly this state
intervention became much less we were
allowed to have one hundred percent
companies in countries like for example
in Venezuela I like in Ecuador where I
also lived and worked as a CEO for quite
some time and this opened up and brought
the more competition into this market
more competitive ateam or productivity
in this market and I think it was good
for the population the local population
again things changed while Latin America
started to move backwards other parts of
the world moved up i mean the fall of
the Berlin Wall of course was and it was
a very very important event which then
basically opened up more than 2.5 almost
3 billion of people to a market-oriented
the economy and those were great
opportunities of course for us for
Nestle and we were very early on
participating in this opening of new
markets and new and and and and new
economic opportunities taking advantage
of the experiences we had many other
parts of the of the world and very
recently I must say Africa for example I
mean Africa is really just opening up
there recently and opens new
opportunities for us and we are very
active now for example working in Africa
or also Middle East Middle East was
another region which was very very state
control and this only opening up very
recently so I think you see if you look
it from a global perspective what you
are seeing is that you have in one part
counter movements on the other part you
you see movements which are opening up
and it's like always a small roller
coaster it goes up and then it comes
back and then we'll come back again in
some part and some other parts will be
more stating the winter than dancing
like this I think as a company you have
to be able you have to you have to
understand first of all the political
social and cultural context in which you
will be working and I think this is
extremely important you cannot suppose
that you can take your model your
cultural model even your ethical model
and your economic model and try to
export this to the rest of the world
what you have to do is to take the
basics your basic fundamental principles
and then see whether a given
country a given region allows you to
adapt to your model to the reality of
this country of the region without
violating the fundamentals of your
belief i think that's basically what you
have to do and this is an ongoing
process and demands a lot of
understanding cultural understanding and
political understanding of what is going
on in this world and when the things are
happening timing becomes an incredible
important part of